to bring you now because sir john major
has written a letter to segregate brody
who of course is a chair of the 1922
committee about benches
he has said that the proposal for the
prime minister to remain in office for
up to three months in his words
having lost the support of his cabinet
his government and his parliamentary
party is unwise and maybe unsustainable
he goes on to say in such a circumstance
the prime minister maintains the power
of patronage and of even greater concern
the power to make decisions which will
affect the lives of those within all
four nations of the united kingdom and
further afield some will argue that his
new cabinet will restrain him i merely
note that his previous cabinet did not
or could not do so
for the overall well-being of the
country mr johnson should not remain in
downing street when he is unable to
command the confidence of the house of
commons for any longer than necessary to
affect the smooth transition
of
government so that letter there you can
see
from the former prime minister sir john
major written to
see graham brady of the 1922 committee
well let's bring in sam coach shall we
our deputy a political editor it's
pretty uh strong words there from the
former leader that's right so john
picking up on the themes that we've been
talking about in the last 20 minutes the
idea that boris johnson who doesn't
really obey convention as we've seen
over the last 72 hours still having lots
of the levers of power a cabinet
expecting him not to make big decisions
but that not really being tenable at a
point that we are at this uh at this
point in uh in britain's history john
major suggesting two alternatives either
the dominic raab solution now i know
that's being talked about by
conservative mps in other words boris
johnson leaves now and then and dominic
rob comes in he will be prime minister
with all the powers but he will be
deemed by his peers to be an acting
prime minister john major's other
alternative solution uh is that the 1922
should get
tory mps alone to select a new prime
minister in a matter of days or a week
or two before the summer recess and then
they should become promised at that
point much much quicker and then the
members in the country would only be
consulted afterwards so they would
basically allow mps to make the choice
and avoid the much more lengthy process
of consulting touring members so there's
john mayer's two solutions but this is a
really big question because the period
that we're in the nature of boris
johnson's exit and the criticisms that
he's received from tory mps many of you
just don't trust him can't leave him
like people like theresa may and david
cameron who did hang around for their
successor to be appointed uh people not
sure that they can trust boris johnson
with that